maybe advice from
from uh from uh og in the game 24 years
i believe you said i have i don't give
um young comics advice anymore so you're
not getting any advice i apologize
nobody does like the good the the when
you you learn the
early on you ask everybody like when i
first started i played sports so early
on i was like yo everybody yo what's up
bro what moves can i do what's the like
you're you're an athlete like you think
it's like a sport but
every every good comedian i ever asked
for advice from said the same thing
which is get on stage got it right so
he's and we do that very general
because
i i guarantee you everybody you asked
and told you to get on stage is burnt
out with the whole talking to young
comics because
it they don't listen and then every
i won't even say anybody is bad anymore
like if you i don't give if you bombing
i'm like you great man because we people
have taken the power away from all that
[ __ ] about no gatekeepers man that's
some [ __ ] like
you need some people to regulate
how
the the
artistry of
a craft goes
like
it's like you would be pissed if what's
your favorite team
uh what sport any sport um call it the
dolphins the miami heat other miami he's
my favorite team okay you would be
pissed if i got drafted number one
right now at 48 years old for the
goddamn oh yeah yeah
i'm like oh no i heard you were the mvp
two times yeah the 40 in overleague yeah
that's the 14-0 league but you
what's the analogy there though
that everybody thinks that everybody is
good but it's definitely
lanes to it and how you get into
something man it you would be pissed if
they you had to draft and they drafted
me i'm like yo no and i'm like yo y'all
know i'm starting right now
sorry kyle you're gonna have to sit this
one out horrible right now he's horribly
slow i'm like but i'm nice though
are you trying to stop my you trying to
stop my hustle right you hating right
right then i get out there and blow my
knee out and y'all gotta pay me 88
million dollars for the next four years
i'm like yeah
persons
man people are weak all right so we're
not going to draft you
[Music]